alright guys we just discovered vault 81
and there is a crazy good weapon in here
that I want to get but first you know I
got to get in there and pretty sure it's
a mission to get in oh ok green aye sir
nice but take this like yeah okay okay I
think they get in there can't do that
wall in combat what the [ __ ] I got some
questions for the folks down here okay
yes she was in combat oh yes stick me in
ah ah ah that feels good it always feels
good hold it right there let you better
start talking
that's 111 got it in vault 111 111 that
way it's here ish paypal and what sort
of business are you looking at take care
of just browsing just lucky that trade
Ashley just looking to do a little
trading is that so and you expect me to
believe that Oh overseer who is it
Edwards
some New Commonwealth traveler not one
of our usual traders well if someone
wants in they can earn it like everyone
else hmm let me speak to them kind of
slow officer Edwards here was just doing
his job I'm sure you can understand yes
for newcomers we like to operate on
exchanges yeah sure
but I'm a fellow vault dweller can't you
just let me in it failed I'm interests
it what is it you need good thing I got
it I'll do it good thing I already got
it started hey hun look you want in you
get the course easy I have tration
you'll be tracking down some fusion
cores okay can I just like drop them Hey
Jude I ain't course [ __ ] I fusion cells
what the [ __ ] okay okay
yeah and I guess I gotta find that
shadow they're gonna find out by I gotta
find it ok ok let's have it care about
around here like all over the place see
any movement though how's that um
I thought I saw a caravan just back here
a little while ago I'm trying to quickly
run back can't caravan looking for my
Caravan the [ __ ] is that hmm what you
got on you Jessica watch
okay hi becca diamond city i think
they're just like carriage roaming
around it the [ __ ] is this Jesus [ __ ]
yeah it's where the shootings are okay
at cell does that's all the fightin
about at a picture
hello sir hello up there oh [ __ ] those
caravan kind of swoon there's a caravan
just like chillin here I just saw one
here like a second ago that [ __ ] go
maybe it's an X alley mm-hmm yes I love
money [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm over here looking for
[ __ ] a holy [ __ ] dickwads ok ok
all right all right let's fast travel to
[ __ ] diamond set a [ __ ] oh wait
that's all these guys that was any
market yeah baby yeah baby let's spread
some fusion cars baby that's a nice
little weapon you got there it's a nice
little flashlight where's my brother I
swear I'm not a sin don't shoot for
god's sakes we're family put the gun
down now he's a sick he'll kill us all
Kyle oh okay show's over there are no
since in diamond city your me get get
get you folks in your damn paranoid
anyway maybe this guy has uh what a mess
okay Oh like I'm trying to trade with
you a [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
where is like the mechanic lady this has
got to be it
weapon right yeah what the [ __ ]
everyone's like busy here i'm going to
enter your building and exited no blade
ones back at the [ __ ] spot what a
[ __ ] disaster [ __ ] is going on yeah
it's [ __ ] up ok ok yes yes everyone
back to their stations ok good good good
i like to partner with you i know you
got some fusion cores in you ok fears
and cuz she ain't cuz if you can sell
now I need fries in car this is madness
ah ok um ok is [ __ ] got one is another
one right here you look like you could
use a drink there any lot of [ __ ] sale
sale sale
one is she must go up do you something
finger and just say yes it's already
under uh what the [ __ ] now stands she's
kind of kid like a how do i wait that's
a good [ __ ] here yeah you're all gonna
see me though ok ok i guess had to wait
like 24 hours this is a [ __ ] does
thats dark here i can I sit here the
[ __ ] oh isn't there chairs in the
barbershop yeah
uh it is five ok it's make it like new
and hopefully don't call [ __ ] lunch
breaks she is sexy and that booty is
beyond me
okay hey you got traitor hey you there
you need a genuine what's authentic
custom-made Hickory swine what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you sir let's see what you
got base no the [ __ ] out of my face
[ __ ] okay yeah right yeah well it put
to have you here I can't let spira 10
minutes to browse something for guys
fusion core one doe all right [ __ ] that
is expensive okay okay i guess i'll put
the goal to [ __ ] and try and counteract
that 23 okay [ __ ] add a lot of money
anything else i could just [ __ ] it sell
um stimpack [ __ ] a ok accept it [ __ ]
a
how do i get that money back k
[ __ ] [ __ ] it okay let's do this let's do
this she lost a [ __ ] ton of money but
[ __ ] it these people love money grubbing
a spittle like a SAG looks is my cousin
total okay okay okay okay the [ __ ] was
that oh great there's a traitor right
here you got a better chance of
surviving I heard if you like drop them
right as you're talking to the person
you don't need to like give it to them
so you're back I take it you got what
overseer McNamara was looking for yes
yes yes yep all three of them all right
I'm opening the door overseer McNamara
myself will meet you at the entrance oh
and behave yourself you start any
trouble we'll toss your ass right back
outside okay good good
all right up an it up at
oh she is [ __ ] sexy oh [ __ ] I'll see
what I can do but you and I both know we
can't keep going on like this sorry
about that as you'll soon see we have a
few maintenance project okay I heard if
he dropped his shut brother fusion
course
wats know it's a miscellaneous rite aid
the [ __ ] is it in weapons no is it in
junk not mods ok [ __ ] two out of three
hello overseer ready to talk now here we
pride ourselves on having maintained a
successful vault over these past two
centuries we'd like to be completely
self-sufficient but there are certain
resources [ __ ] ready to talk now yes yes
pride ourselves on having maintained a
successful we'd like to be completely
something huh I'm impressed you maintain
a successful thanks I owe it to but some
here would disagree interaction is a
good thing the Commonwealth is improving
excuse me overseer
ready now yes yes we pride ourselves on
having maintained a successful like to
be completely self true the hannah
thought it thanks oh that's some hair
bright interaction is a good thing so
I've heard that's why i like to use it
speaking of if you're ready i can take
those fusion cores from you of course
thank you dr. pen oh [ __ ] they must have
fixed that hi ma'am what about his I'll
allow it if he's lived this long if you
need anything okay I guess that's it
guys uh try to keep the money but you
didn't [ __ ] work so I hope y'all
enjoy guys help y'all joy